hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help so in
today's video I'm going to be sharing
how I use Evernote to manage my to-do
list I use this for both business and
personal reasons and I'm going to share
with you how I do it and show you how
you can do it as well it's pretty easy
for everything that I want to manage
I'll create a separate stack so here's
one stack LTO place to the checkout and
this is a list of things that I want to
do in Toronto so TOS hangs for Toronto
and anytime I find an interesting blog
post or somebody's talking about a new
thing happen in Toronto that I want to
check out I will record it here so this
is a new board game that's opened up
book board games cafe that's opened up
in Toronto this is a place of different
ramen places in the city that I want to
check out and so I'll make a list of
things that that I want to go see when
it's done I'll put it in a new folder
called done so there's two different
notebooks under each stack so if I just
click on the teal places to check out
this is the list of things that I
haven't done yet when I've done it I'll
move it to the done folder and then
you'll see you know what's here if you
ever want to go back into your archive
to see what was done so there's no order
of priority on here you could if you
wanted to you could put meal number one
number two and then you could sort it by
the title and it will then be in
alphabetical order if you really need to
do that but this is just a list of
things that I want to get done and when
it's finished I put it to the done
folder I also use it for business
reasons one of the companies that I've
invested in TDS is a salsa company I
can't show you the task because of
confidentiality reasons but same thing
here I've created a new stack called TDS
notes TDS notes are the things that I
have to get done so the six things that
I have to do and there's two things that
I have already done so it's a quick way
to look at what's on your to-do list I
move it into a separate folder either
archive or done when you finish them if
you need to look at them ever again and
I like it because this list is easy to
sort by different stock so if I have my
personal list I have a business list I
can have multiple ones if I want and
it's available on all my computers and
devices so I can access from
my iPad from my laptop from my cellphone
it makes it really easy to do it is
actually pretty easy just create oops
you do that's some here so we'll create
a new notebook so say this is business
tasks then we want to add it to a stock
at the stock we'll create a new one and
we can rename this business tasks so now
it's been put here business tasks so
this is where would actually put all my
- dues and then you can also right-click
and we can do if we want create a new
notebook and this can be our done or
archived whatever you want to call it
already exist so we'll do it done
business so here I can start adding
different notes of things that I need to
do
call Hugo whatever it is and then I can
have my whole list of things I need to
get done and when I'm finished I could
put it into the done and then I can
always have my list update of the things
I need to actually get done so that's
how I use Evernote to manage my to-do
lists still something that is pretty new
for me what I'm doing and how I'm using
Evernote but I find it super helpful for
those of you who are watching if you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below makes you want to do more for
you and if you have a comment about this
video or question about how I use
Evernote or question about your business
I'd love to try to answer it for you if
you want to leave it in the comment
section I always read the comments and I
really love seeing them coming so thank
you and I will see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]